was Kenny's solution when Charles got a
leg cramp several seasons
here are the possible answers stomp your
feet have Kareem care I have Akeem carry
you oh load management or squeeze your
top lip so the joke is I'm in the joke
as I'm part of the job I hate working
here sometimes do you remember what it
was I remember it's not funny Kenny yeah
it is it really is here it is oh
oh crapage
we
just squeeze the top of the Dead series
you always got jokes around here
now I'm telling you you didn't want to
do it okay catch a crap
squeeze it it works early it's not it
did work that did the did the cramp go
away in time eventually I'm calling HR
man no so you're supposed to squeeze it
right y'all can't be returned
like this and then it would have went
away
that was a tremendous mess no tremendous
tremendous huh